you
[Music]
welcome everyone to this session on the
good bad and the ugly of ml in network
systems applying ml to a problem needs
no real motivation or push in 2018 we're
seeing a huge surge in in in developing
ml techniques for a lot of large-scale
network systems and with the huge amount
of data and computing power available
this actually makes it quite feasible
and and of course Microsoft has been in
the forefront of you know applying data
at huge scales to do you know large
scale systems issues however there is a
growing voice maybe even the silent
majority of voices in the systems and
networking community that is clamoring
for more principled solutions you know
they're concerned that we're building
solutions without quite understanding
what they actually do this session
instance intends to weigh right into
this system you know what are the
network systems for which ml is
appropriate the fact that we have built
systems are built with abstractions does
it make it you know more amenable to
using blackbox ml based techniques and
finally do we even need full
understanding of the solutions as the
the so-called traditionalists insist to
discuss all these questions and more we
have a panel you know of researchers in
this space and we'll start with Balaji
Prabhakar from Stanford Balaji is a
professor at Stanford his research is
largely in the space of self programming
networks particularly in the context of
cloud computing platforms and data
centers Balaji has a long list of awards
will I won't list all of them but I
would just note the that that is one the
Erlang price from the applied
probability society and the role of
Davidson price from the University of
Cambridge and he is a Sloan fellow I
Triple E and ACM fellow Esbern look
thank you hi graphin already I'm going
to
take a position and my main thesis is
that on the good bad ugly side I'm gonna
say it's good okay
what's ugly and sometimes can be bad is
the hype but in and of themselves
there's nothing wrong with ideas is how
we end up using them or worse how we end
up make a bigger deal out of them so my
some of my background is theoretical and
so the scientific modeling process
always goes on a knife-edge there are a
few theorems that give universality but
other than that things tend to be for
tractability we make some models and
they work by and large there's some
well-known combinations like linear
systems go with Gaussian noise really
well and that goes with quadratic cost
functions really well and that's a
fairly large amount of optimal control
theory stochastic control runs on those
three assumptions people have tried
relaxing any one of these and it's not
been easy okay nobody's heard from those
people who've tried to relax these
assumptions they've gone off into the
woods and never come back
similarly networking we know there is a
game Markovian assumption reddit Poisson
arrivals and exponential services small
variations but otherwise by and large
that's a successful modeling class what
happens when we leave this world of you
know modeling assumptions don't quite
work or you now now want to capture
something in more exact detail that is
where lots of data in these days and
when combined with neural networks and
ml can actually help okay
it helps us to capture something that's
actual an actual system where the
modeling assumptions have got a some
distance but now we want to be more
exact than that okay what that does is
it does it does certainly leave the
burden of understanding upon us and I
mean I'm okay if first we get success
and then understanding usually me
prefers understanding first and then
success then we can declare
correctly but you know people who have
had observations that for which theories
will come later that's fine it's worth
just saying sharing an anecdote with
Niels Bohr but about news for or
involving him he had a scientific friend
visit with him at some summer home that
he had in the mountain somewhere and
banged on the door frame of this house
there was a horseshoe which is
well-known as a good luck charm
so scientific friends said surely you
know professor ball you don't believe in
this superstition I only said well I
don't believe in it but they say it
works whether you believe in it or not
okay it's not a bad thing to keep in
mind for the topic of this panel I want
to take two specific uses for neural
networks first is so-called function
approximation the well known to have the
property of approximating functions too
late neural networks are universal was
long ago theorem of Andrew berends and
second is that when combined with
hardware of the GPU TPU type this
ability to approximate function can
vastly speed up I was very useful for us
in networking speed of computations I'm
gonna give you some examples one example
supporting both is from self programming
networks so I'll tell you what that is
and briefly also tell you some work I've
been doing with the students watching
Cuddy's money
Kotaro and also garden which times our
colleague who specializes in VR computer
vision and finally I was at a Simon's
Institute program in Berkeley last
season last spring you know the one this
went by and we had a physicist from
Caltech who's involved in elementary
particle physics is Large Hadron
Collider and they also used neural
networks in pretty much the same way
that I'm going to describe it for the
same reasons also
so self programming networks is a
research program at Stanford Mendel
doesn't blow and I
working on it together with a bunch of
students and the the infrared learners
in our blue because that's where we've
used some neural networks and so again
once like what what is self-driving
self-programming networks think of
self-driving car you take a plain old
car if you had sense and control to it
then become Stanley the sub driving car
this is Sebastian on the on the trunk
hunter so in the under hood similarly we
would take a plain old data center and
our focuses on data centers so in other
words I'm not advocating what we're
doing or why they do internet yet
because there's some particular
assumptions we made and you had sense
and control to it and we want to use
that to you know forms are so
programming networks I don't have time
to tell you more about it
where we sense how we control it's
mostly its NIC based approach and what
that allows us to do is to run some new
applications that couldn't run on the
old plain old data center so it allows
us to run this because it has additional
functionality like a very accurate time
stamping in the service and so on so in
this world neural networks I want to get
to it comes in the following way we've
taken a sort of tomography type approach
to measurement ie look at ingress and
egress times or packets admix when you
have this for a whole bunch of packets
you're in the world of solving
simultaneous linear equations to
determine from the total time how much
time was spent in each box okay the
algorithm for this is lasso one the one
we use so you're looking at the total
delay D a is the adjacency matrix that
decides what path the packet took cues
the queuing delays of the switches it's
visiting and it's a noise noise is
variable while and Nick time stamping
inaccuracies various things like this we
worked on this and tested it in the
Google's 40g test per the internal
production Network and whereas other
places internet data central Stanford
but this is the algorithm so given the
end-to-end delay
estimate individual queue queuing delays
or a certain interval
this works but with slow the lasso
algorithm scales poorly with the size of
the network there are faster
implementations of last orbiting even so
we want to see if we can just teach a
neural network to do this what that
means this take an algorithm like lasso
it has its input output map that defines
a function and take the input output
pairs lots and lots and lots of them and
train a neural network with it you have
to remember after all with just
inverting noisy linear equations okay if
there was no noise in the equation
without determine inverse is just
another linear system okay so you expect
a priori the neural network should have
a good chance so it turns out just a two
layer is completely as shallow as you
can get a neural network of the basic
revenue type it's good enough so what's
the result look like on the top is
reconstruction accuracy this is the
first chart you can have different size
networks
laso has root mean square error which is
you can think of it as how many packets
like roughly three full sized 1500 byte
packets roughly that's the error the
second column is near electric strain
with ground truth when you have it
available and third is new network train
with the output of lasso itself okay and
so as you can see it's pretty accurate
but it is not much loss of accuracy but
the killer is the second thing lots of
scales pulley as I said before so every
milliseconds what the data takes you
more than a millisecond depending on
size and network you can get as bad as a
second but if you train a neural network
you can stick you know be tracking time
okay so that's an example of function
approximation capability as well as
hardware acceleration okay so it's my
first example second one is again very
briefly even briefer than this is this
work with money
Kotaro
who's such an students as I said such an
and his students have hired a team of
using Wi-Fi signals for various things
in this case its localization and
there's a VR headset that's moving Wi-Fi
signals are captured the goal is to
localize based on the signals there's a
well-known 70s mid seventies algorithm
called music that does it and it sort of
cancels the indirect path it's not right
it does but you get a 60 centimeter
error okay when music does the
localization in work that took money
more than a year and a half because you
really it's not like off-the-shelf ml
it's like you have to work wrestle with
it I actually thought he wouldn't even
succeed maybe there's not an easy
function to approximate but he did
there's a submission on this which
four-centimeter rather okay and it's
also really fast
by comparison music so as an example
second second example and the last one
is just I'm gonna I really encourage you
to read it because I was quite impressed
with way the physics folks are doing it
this is from CERN I'm happy to share
this with folks who you know you're on
the URL so basically what happens in
these sort of you know Large Hadron
Collider is that some elementary
particle some something is held over
here and like some really fast in comes
and bangs it and then stuff like muons
gluons all these guys come out and you
trace the trajectory of these particles
that's their business but the data
generated is so huge that they had a
sensor it they can't store everything
and it starts the article starts by
saying in the 60s people used to pour
over this you know in the sixties people
used to pour over these thing and you
know there's images and reconstruct the
trajectories to find out if they've
found a new elementary particle or not
like the Higgs boson type thing is
showing up or not and then the learning
revolution has just begun and it was it
was based on sort of grid computing that
was introduced in the 2000s and what
they're now doing is just it's exactly
reconstruction so my problem of the
inverse given the overall delay finally
the queue sizes that's called in
problem there is a forward equation is d
equals a q + and the inverse equation is
given define me Q there's another
inverse problem okay and inverse
problems are in MRI
all of those are inverse problems and
there's another inverse problem and
they're sort of most recent work has
been about training these neural
networks to just do the inverse problems
and find the trajectories okay
so what that we couldn't have lasso for
them is this sort of classical quantum
mechanics laws and then they just
trained them okay so I think it's
hardware acceleration plus all that is
been officially used in this case as
well okay so with that I'll stop hoping
is that if there are any burning
questions one or two we could bring it
up now but if you have more broader
questions you know we ask that you keep
it for the panel at the end any quick
questions while Bruce gets set up okay
yeah Bruce gets era Bruce is from Duke
University his interests are in
large-scale networks as well as his
research prior to that Bruce was at
Carnegie Mellon University where he
helped launch the Akamai CDN service and
he was the first vice president of
research and development for Akamai
where he continues to hold a role as
vice president for research Bruce's work
has won the SEC on networking systems
award as well as the I Triple E cyber
security innovation of what
we're going to go with VGA
Thank You Ganesh it's nice to be here I
have to say that I am giving this
presentation with some trepidation
because I I don't really use ml very
much in my work I tried to think of the
best justification I could find for
myself as a speaker and it occurred to
me that I have ml in my middle name so
I'm a traditional systems designer I
like to design big systems the biggest
example is the Akamai CDN large parts of
which I designed I like to try to
optimize these systems and I like to fix
them and one of the things I've
discovered over and over is that
whenever you take measurements and look
at how your system is performing you
find out that it's broken broken either
not functioning correctly or it's just
performing very poorly and there's a
methodology that I've used many times to
try to either improve systems or design
systems with new capabilities that I
call data-driven design of network
systems and so the idea is that you look
around for existing systems that are
already deployed on a large scale and
from which you can collect a lot of data
possibly data of different types and
then you you you think about how how
could we marry these datasets to help us
evaluate new system designs maybe for a
system that does something different or
that does the same thing but in a very
different way and so one example of this
may be the the first one I was involved
in was there was a new system that had
been developed at Carnegie Mellon around
2000 or so for purely peer-to-peer
delivery of live or real-time video
called n system multi
cast this this was not my work it was it
was quite young and Sanjay Rao and and
and several others they won the sig
metrics test of time award for their
paper describing n system multicast but
they didn't have a very good way of
evaluating whether or not this system
could really hold up under real
workloads and so one of the things we
did was we gathered all the logs from
from Akamai's real-time video delivery
system and then we use that to drive
simulations of esm and the kinds of
questions we were interested in were
well when there's a massive flash crowd
at the beginning of some kind of
scheduled event and peers are joining
and leaving rapidly is the system stable
and and most of the time we found that
in fact even without the kind of
dedicated infrastructure that that
Akamai had deployed for its real-time
streaming network the ESM was was still
mostly successful let me give you
another example of of this kind of work
so here's a fact that maybe people don't
know but TLS certificate revocation
check eNOS is broken in a bad way and
here's how your mobile device doesn't
check for certificate revocation okay so
what this means is if if somebody you go
to some website where you provide your
password and and maybe you use the same
password on a lot of websites and
somebody has stolen that sites private
key somehow maybe through a bug like the
heartbleed bug and and somehow they have
interfered with DNS and you've gone to
an impostor site and despite the fact
that the true owner of that certificate
has reported it as no longer valid and
put it on a revocation list your device
will not check for that and I know this
because I've tested all the mobile
devices
Android devices iPhones I couldn't find
any example in which any device ever
checked for certificate revocation and
the reason they don't is that it's too
expensive this one of the things I found
a little frustrating this morning going
to talks about formally verifying
security properties making sure your
implementations of the protocols are
correct and so on is that there are
these other economic reasons why whole
parts of the protocol just aren't
implemented and so on mobile devices
they don't do secure certificate
revocation checking because it would be
too much bandwidth to download the whole
list of revoke certificates or it would
take too long to contact an OCSP server
to ask is this certificate valid or
there's there's new protocols like OCSP
stapling but only you know two or three
percent of servers are supporting that
so it's just not done and this is a
crying shame so we started thinking
about is there data out there that would
make it possible to solve this problem
and it is not difficult to find the list
of all the revoked certificates because
there on the certificate revocation
lists but what's harder to find is a
list of all the valid certificates until
recently when Google was so annoyed that
Symantec had made some fake certificates
that they launched something called
certificate transparency and now they
they're basically pressuring certificate
authorities to put into just to like
spice up my talk I'm going to say a
blockchain type of log every certificate
that they issue and in addition to that
there's some research projects that have
been going around scanning the whole
ipv4 address space pulling every
certificate they can from port 443 so
suddenly we have a new data set we
didn't have before which is all the
valid certificates so you had the
invalid ones before and now we have the
valid ones
so this suggests by the way it's a lot
of certificates we're talking about tens
of millions this suggests
a way to represent in a very compact
data structure complete information
about every certificate indicating
whether it's been revoked or not and the
structure is called a filter cascade so
the idea is that you take all the revoke
certificates and you insert them into a
bloom filter now that would be fine as a
solution except it'd be really unfair if
there was a false positive and some
website certificate is now marked as
revoked because there was a you know
just a bad collision so then you you
take all the non revoke certificates and
you you you ask okay are there any false
positives and you for all the false
positives you create a bloom filter to
hold those and there are a lot more non
revoked certificates than revoked so
that it's important that the first level
you use you you insert the not the
revoked ones so you can have a small
table but with a really small false
positive rate and then you say okay what
about revoke certificates that
accidentally get marked as false
positives meaning they would be
considered as not revoked and you make a
little okay so you get this geometric
decrease and I it turns out that this
filter cascade it has 43 levels but you
only expect to do ten hashes to look up
the status of any certificate and the
whole thing only takes 1.1 megabytes to
represent the precise status of every
certificate and there's a lower bound an
information theoretic lower bound of
0.77 megabytes so you're not going to do
much better and so basically there today
there are 60 million valid certificates
that number is about 40 million higher
than it was two years ago maybe 50
million because of let's encrypt and
today there this in September anyway
850,000 revoked certificates and so that
would take 1.1 megabytes but actually
the list changes very slowly so you can
just publish diffs
and the whole thing is only 40 kilobytes
per day okay so this is an example of
sort of data-driven system design they
say look what what's out there how could
we exploit it now I'm going to say a
little bit about machine learning the
application of machine learning in
computer networking is old so here's a
paper from a survey from 2008 that's
been cited a thousand times okay traffic
classification this is a thing people
have done for a long time trying to
figure out okay is this an attack what
kind of application is running here this
is an old application I was thinking a
little bit about places where you might
use machine learning in the context of
content delivery networks so one of the
things that Akamai tries to do is
predict for each client on the Internet
like a billion clients which of our
servers would give best performance and
this is an example where you have
multiple data sets of different
character you have past performance you
have network measurements you have
network topology information you're
trying to make a prediction and here you
could try to use machine learning
another application is trying to figure
out is this a legitimate client we have
a lot of trouble with botnets trying to
break into banking customers so you know
we want to develop a reputation for a
client or estimate the physical location
of a client this is easy if there's some
way for a client to click on the allow
button to give up their location but
Akamai doesn't touch clients the same
way that say a content provider does and
these kinds of things work best when the
penalty for false positives is low so
it's okay if whatever algorithm you're
using does poorly as long as it doesn't
hurt that much when you make the wrong
decision so when we decide a client
suspicious we don't ban it but we rate
limit or if we decide a participant in
our peer-to-peer content delivery system
Akamai has tens of millions of clients
in
system that does this is suspicious we
just kick it out and say you have to
download from the Cydia okay I'll finish
they're trying to say data-driven and
machine learning is a good thing for
networking but I see there's something
different between you and projects since
the first talk is more talking about the
catalyst of success of machine learning
networking is because we have more
expensive more more complex models right
neural network is but you're not talking
about the catalyst is because we have
most all of sudden we have more data
right we have more data from Akamai or
have more data from Google it's an
explosion of small of data that is the
kind of driving force behind this so is
it true that you think having more data
is kind of a relatively more important
to have more complex models okay so I'm
not sure that was exactly the point I
wanted to make but I do like the way you
summarized it that the fact that we have
more data is giving us new opportunities
new ways of designing systems and
perhaps ml is a tool that can be used to
help do that that's a good point for
follow-up as well model complexity next
up we have Dave mods who's a
distinguished engineer at Microsoft he
leads
Asher's physical networking team his
team builds the software and network
devices that that that connects you know
Microsoft's largest services including
the Azure public cloud and Bing prior to
that day was at Microsoft autopilot and
then before that he had spent five years
at MSR and Dave has won the second test
of
I'm award as well as the ACM system
software
great thanks Ganesh so I'm here talking
about the work of the azure physical
networking team we're called the
physical networking team because you
might imagine we're in charge of
actually getting packets between all the
servers inside of our data centers and I
want to talk to you a little bit about
the environment into work so we're
building really large Network hundreds
of thousands of links of each data
center hundreds of data centers around
the world you know when you talk about
large scale and large data sets the
network is very good at generating those
kinds of things and just to be clear the
number one job for my team is high
availability it's making sure that every
packet that gets sent by every service
running in our network actually makes it
across that network and received
appropriately by the destination service
and the challenge we have is that at
this large scale the law of large
numbers is not your friend yes we see
lots of nice median behavior but it
turns out nobody cares about what
happens at the 50th percentile people
who care about what happened at these
strange edge conditions what is the very
high nines percentile of your behavior
of packet loss and everything else and
so instead of Occam's razor where the
simplest explanation is the most likely
you get Murphy's Law there is something
crazy happening in some part of the
network that's going to generate really
weird behavior and my team's job is to
go figure out what that is and stop it
so you take a network this is actually
sort of a shot of a rendering of one
small part of our network in one small
data center you can see all the
interconnectivity and go find that
proverbial needle in a haystack
and sadly we're actually pretty good at
it but sadly des does often take us
quite a bit of time and again the time
to mitigate these problems is also very
important because our customers are
suffering they are bleeding money
reputation and everything while we go
and try and find these problems and
resolve them so how can machine learning
help us with this so I'm gonna have sort
of a mixed message I'm going to show you
a couple of problems where I think ml
probably has some things to offer us and
we've been getting some benefits I'm
gonna try and characterize some things
where ml is probably not the best
approach and I hope I have enough time
and with a little bit of commentary
about from a practitioners guide if
you're an element person and want to
work with system scientists or you
assist some scientists you want to work
with ml people how can you cross the
knowledge gap between those two I'll
talk about sort of the three examples
and I'll come back to sort of the the
commentary text on the side as we go
through let me start with a problem
called layer 1 topology generation so
the basic problem here is we want to
keep our network from failing I want to
keep say our optical network from
failing from various data centers or
regions in our network being partitioned
from the rest of the network due to
fiber cuts or other fiber failures now
you're like hey guys this is an easy
problem you tell me the availability
distributions time between failure time
to repair for your fiber and we can
predict what the availability and what
you know the of any particular region
should be the problem is the following
fiber providers a don't really know this
information and be in if they did
they're going to lie and they're not
really going to give us as someone who's
trying to acquire fiber to build our
network accurate information and so the
question is given the fact that we have
to acquire new fiber paths all the time
to continue to to build out and extend
our network we need to acquire enough
fiber paths and the right kinds of fiber
paths to hit the availability targets
that we want how can we actually predict
what this time between failure and time
to repair distributions are going to be
for a new fiber path now we have a large
bunch of fiber paths already in our
inventory and so if we could take our
experience that we've actually measured
from existing fiber paths and figure out
how to apply that to estimate the
characteristics for new fiber we could
do a pretty good job challenge here is
there are a lot and lot and lot of
relevant dimensions there's where the
Fiber goes there's how many construction
sites it goes through there's how many
people live along that fiber there's how
many kilometers our aerial fly about how
many kilometers are buried fiber lots
and lots of other variables that can be
extracted for each of these paths and
unfortunately we don't want to Paulo G
decisions or fiber path selection
decisions to be made based on human
emotions there's oh we bought some fiber
from this company last time and they
really like were nice to us we like them
so we should buy more fiber from them or
I know this person who worked on that
project and they're very reputable so
what's by right that's not the right
approach to this so we've actually had
some pretty good initial results in sort
of this overall problem space this is
data from not exactly the problem I just
described but a very related one of
trying to estimate what the availability
of particular portions of our topology
is going to be based on our estimated
and then simulated data versus the
actual availability so the green bars
represent our actual observed
availability the blue is the average of
our simulated and estimated availability
and you can see in some cases we
undershirt in some cases we overshoot
we're doing a lot better than random
chance here and so again that gives us
hope this is the kind of thing where
classification algorithms can extract
dimensionality that's not obvious to
human being that is still going to give
us good business value is this ml is a
statistics should we be using PCA or
other kinds of straight stats versus
more harder to explain classification
algorithms that's a really interesting
conversation to have maybe we'll talk
about during the panel another problem
optical performance optimization so we
have what we call open line systems
microsoft's actually been one of the
companies out there driving towards this
rather than buying a highly integrated
system from one of these standard
optical vendors where you have to buy
all the equipment from them we're trying
to get to a disaggregated ecosystem
where you can buy line systems and
amplifiers wrong company transponders
from another and mix it all match it
together one of the reasons is because
these systems when that you open them up
actually have lots of parameters that we
can tune to maximize the number of bits
per second they can actually be
delivered across any individual piece of
glass these are things like the transmit
power of the receive power
how many lamp amplifiers you put along
the path all of this kind of stuff is
this a good machine learning problem
okay we've got a bunch of parameters and
we want to set them appropriately this
is a control system a problem in any one
sense I'm gonna argue no this isn't why
availability is our job number one right
so I can't actually tolerate many of the
errors that a machine learning system
might put in due to miss classification
or miss estimation of the parameters
- I have a really good set of a physics
textbook that more or less describes
exactly the plant model of how this
optical line system and all the
amplifiers and power generation and
noise perturbations is going to work so
I can use much more standard control
theory because I have that forward plant
model to say if I use a set of
parameters what's actually gonna happen
what's gonna happen to my signal and I
can then spin that loop as often and
only when needed to try and tune this
system okay if you've got it something
where the physical layer is well
understood I don't quite see what we're
gonna use ml to try and do this even
though I do see a lot of people out
there trying to use ml kinds of
approaches it's this sort of problem
third problem network availability
hopefully by now you can sort of see
sort of where the thinking is
essentially if you've got a really big
data set you've got the potential for
machine learning problem if what's
underlying that big data set is a bunch
of physical laws or properties that are
well understood you understand the
interactions between all the variables
they're probably better off using
standards control theory and some kind
of forward plant model to drive your
driver system if you're in a world where
you don't even know which of these
variables are actually salient or most
important you don't know which ones are
going to be most descriptive in
predicting the outcome that's where a
bunch of machine learning types of
algorithms can come up and actually help
surface the much better model than any
human being is going to come up with
let's look at this last one network
availability so again let's talk about
preventing failures now it turns out
when you have a big complicated network
like this I have lots of redundant pads
if any device or link fails and actually
shuts itself off when it fails I am
totally fine the problem we have is what
we call gray switch failures where some
piece of equipment actually starts
dropping some small fraction of the
packets that go through it but not
enough that it actually fails stops and
takes itself out of service when it's
stays in service while dropping packets
now that's a problem my team has to go
through and find the device and shut it
down and there's going to be customer
pain and impact until we do so this
really is the needle in a haystack
problem
again we have lots of different data
sources in part because we've tried many
many different approaches to this
problem so for example we've set up ping
meshes we have all of our server sending
ping packets through the network and
we're measuring latency and failure
rates we have targeted probe systems
which are actually you know sending
different types of probed packets of
different kinds to try and simulate
different or stimulate different
behaviors and we can target more probes
on the links that we think are might be
dropping packets
we've got error messages basically
debugging printf that are coming back
from the switches that may or may not
indicate a problem on the switches
themselves we've got these end and
service health metrics all the services
running across the network which are
telling us I'm happy I'm not happy I'm
getting worse I'm getting better and
essentially the problem we now have is
how do we combine all these things to
localize the problem we have a whole
bunch of noise coming out of the best
classification and recognition systems
that we were able to build individually
and so this is now one of those meta
level things one set of technology for
this would be boosting you know how can
we use boosting is a way to sort of pull
more signal out of the noise being
generated by each of these other smaller
classification systems we've also you
know used to quest a gradient descent
and other kinds of algorithms in a fault
propagation model to try and work
backwards to what is the most likely
explanation for the set of symptoms that
we're currently observing but this again
is a really rich and important area and
something where again we have these
large data sets and sometimes they're
pretty well labeled we know whether the
services were he'll a healthy or not
coming back to that final point about
you know practitioners guide I'm not a
machine learning person I am a
networking researcher as well at heart
and the thing I've seen the most is what
we call the knowledge gap there's some
people who know machine learning you
know the algorithms they're really
really well I've got a bunch of network
scientists who know how a sik's work and
how Asics fail and how to look at
service data and the problem we have is
when people are more interested in their
own field than they are at solving the
problem these people can't talk to each
other or they just fail to talk to each
other and so you know for data Sciences
people who want to come work with
systems people I think the key thing is
you know having to be come more
interested in solving the problem
learning more about the Pacific specific
subject matter material then and even
knowing in the classification algorithms
in order to make forward progress to
basically establish what are the metrics
what are the salient dimensions to be
able to work through the data and sort
through it to come up with better
outcomes and I've experienced some
positive examples of I've experienced
some Nevitt examples of this and I'm
glad to be part of this conversation
here and talk more so thank you
[Applause]
questions okay next up we have heat heat
is from Stanford he's an assistant
professor his research is in network
systems and and you know it mostly cuts
across traditional abstraction
boundaries and uses statistical
techniques Keith you know has won the
the second dissertation award and and
you know and and and prior to being a
professor he was a staff reporter at The
Wall Street Journal and a later work at
K splice which was acquired by Oracle
where he was the vice president of
product management and business
development and according to his webpage
was also responsible for cleaning the
bathroom yeah welcome Keith thank you
I don't know which input I'm on I think
he's working on it
perfect all right thank you very much
I'm not an expert in in anything but I
was invited to be on this panel so I'm
gonna do my best I think I think I want
to do with biology machine learning is
good and I think one thing I want to
highlight is it when people say machine
learning they mean a bunch of different
things I think that's sort of maybe at
least three paradigms in which we talk
about using machine learning in the
context of deploying an operational
system so a paradigm one is is what I'll
call learn then deploy so you learn
something machine learning produces an
artifact you know someone runs in a data
center on a you know million core GPU
all kinds of stuff we produce an awesome
artifact a learned network and then we
deploy that network that's paradigm one
paradigm two is about learning in real
life we deploy something and then we
learn and we learn over time something's
in the field we learn in paradigm three
I'm going to call we learn from the
machines not the computer learning but
machine learning teaches us about our
own thinking like these are sort of
three different ways we could talk about
machine learning in the context of
network systems I guess I have sort of
three different views a paradigm one
which I think is currently the the
dominant one people talk about in my
opinion it's often harder than we expect
I'm sort of not obvious but it's often
tricky paradigm to this deploy and learn
that continuous learning in the field I
think it's quite valuable and I think we
should we should research it but it's
hard because of the nature of network
systems I think there's other domains
where this is probably easier but in
networks it's not so easy and I think we
should be working on those problems and
part im3 this idea that we can learn
from the experience of teaching a
machine to match us at some capability I
mean that's a sort of old-fashioned like
1960s view but I think it's still true
today I think we should talk more in
this term so I'm gonna try and talk
about in that sense so a paradigm one
learn then deploy why do I say it's
often harder than we expect well I have
been bit by this so here's a paper for
me that was a 10 s di 2013 about a
machine learning congestion control
algorithm uses Bayesian reasoning for
congestion control the sprout algorithm
and you can see on this graph the best
algorithms have the lowest delay and the
best throughput so the best algorithms
are our algorithms sprout up into the
right we're very proud of that now what
happens in
life so we deployed this around the
world and five years later here's a
result that was taken yesterday on the
t-mobile network in California same kind
of graph here sprout so still sort of up
into the right but it's not really as
dominant as we showed in our paper from
five years ago there's a whole bunch of
other algorithms that are sort of on
this purrito frontier that's in America
this is the same place we've measured
when we did our paper how about here's a
result that was literally this morning
in New Delhi India on the Airtel network
here's my algorithm it's terrible this
sucks
can I say that here I don't know work
there okay thank you
so yeah this learn then deploy I learned
I wrote a paper about it the paper won
an award
I got a professorship now we learn in
the field it doesn't actually work at
least not outside America this is not a
good paradigm for anyone other than me I
mean I'm the beneficiary but not
everyone else so that's my algorithm
here's a different algorithm vivace this
was published in SDI 2018 here's the
publication again we see really good
performance here which shares the link
is flows enter and leave this is in the
paper here's a result again this morning
in Brazil same algorithm but again it's
quite different from the paper we see
the first flow sort of dominates the
second flow much less the third flow
much less so there's a difference again
between sort of the learn and then the
deploy here's a different paper this is
the Pensieve paper that was at sigcomm
the most recent sig cop excuse me this
is a learned scheme for deciding which
video bitrate to send a user over a
network where there's unpredictability
about the network and whether they're
going to need to rebuff IRR and you want
to have good quality video but you don't
want to run out of a buffer so this is
in the paper if you take the same
learned artifact and you deploy it over
similar network some students in my
class tried and they got these results
so again the learn it works when you
learn it but later when you deploy it
something's different and it doesn't
work anymore and the only way to know
this is to you know teach a networking
class where you can compel students to
reproduce papers and then they have to
do it I mean it's not actually easy to
learn this information I mean we put a
lot of effort into deploying this global
infrastructure whose conclusion is that
I was wrong but if we hadn't done that
we would never know I would be going
around blissfully talking about how
great I was
here's another one so bbr this is an
algorithm from Google this was published
in ACM queue and they say bbr convert
towards a fair share of the bottom like
bandwidth and at worst case the
oppositional algorithms might grab more
than their fair share bbr could have
less than its fair share that's the
claim in the paper here is a slide
presentation from ripe 76 just a few
months ago and the gentleman from APNIC
finds that's just not true here's a
cubic flow and it suddenly when the bbr
flow starts it crushes the cubic flow
so there's learn Google learned it but
then when you deploy it you get
something quite different so what they
find is that bbr is not a scalable
approach you know it works great when
just a few users use it like one big
company but not one you know lots of
people use it is bbr a failure not
necessarily because now there's gonna be
a bbr 2.0 you know we'll see what
happens here's another example so
network systems sort of a broad feel
let's talk about search engines there's
a lot of interest in using the data from
search engines to learn things about the
real world and in 2008 Google had a
paper about learning about the flu from
the from the search queries that they
gots the idea here is to learn a model
to predict the real-world flu incidents
by correlating search engine queries
against government flu data which is
released on a sort of you know two to
three week time lag they learn the model
and then they deployed in real time to
break flu in advance of the government
to help direct vaccines more efficiently
so this was on the front page of the New
York Times aches a sneeze a Google
search it was in nature that was on
Charlie Rose and they Google put this
plot on their website and you can see
the predictor which is in blue does
really good against the real life data
which is in yellow this is this is what
they put on their website they don't
show you is this it's actually the vast
majority this plot is training data so
that this is what it is but it's
actually only a tiny bit of here it was
not trained on so this is heart so they
learned it on this training data here I
mean I annotated the figure but then
when they actually deploy it this is not
deployment it's I mean they call it
historical estimates but it wasn't
deployed to store eclis it when they
actually do play it this is what happens
it goes crazy and we don't know why
Google eventually sort of they kept
trying to fix this it kept screwing up
they eventually gave up on it we don't
know why this happens I mean maybe
someone in the audience knows why I
don't know why
here's another example spam filtering
another sort of broadly construed
network systems problem spam assassins a
spam filtering engine has a very clever
sort of community approach the idea is
anyone can propose a spam filtering
decision rule and it's okay because a
central party learns the best weights
for each of these rules a sort of a
panel of experts so anyone can
contribute a putative expert people
learn the best essentially they learn
the best rate so if your expert is sort
of nonsense they'll just give it a
weight of zero and if it happens to be
very predictive they'll give it a strong
weight and those weights are then
deployed in the field so in 2007 you
know people pros various rules some
proposed a rule and the rule was does
the Year match 200 and then any
character you know the date and it
turned out that caught a lot of spam
because a lot of spam is sent for a date
in the future like a date like 2012
which would have been in the future so
that would have been spam so this had an
extremely low false positive rate when
they learned it people can see why right
because it's in 2007 that they're
learning it so what happened January 1st
2010 spam assassin started calling every
message spam this is sort of very easy
to see case where do they learn then
deploy it just falls down in the real
world because you know they have this
idea that the algorithms were black
boxes they didn't have to know how they
worked they just looked at empirically
how well they worked and they weighted
them according to the real performance
that did not work when time of all come
it's a very clear case here if you
depend on the date as soon as you hit
2010 time's gonna evolve so what was the
fix for this how do you fix this problem
what was that well they just changed it
to 20/20 that's their new decision rule
yeah so I think the lesson here is that
it is very easy to fool yourself and I
think Fineman says you are the easiest
person to fool let's learn then deploy
it is a challenging parrot pattern and
empirically very very smart people and
very very smart mega-corporations
embarrass themselves going on television
two minutes thank you you know with
premature declarations of success so I
think we have to keep that in mind
so paradigm 2 is sort of okay let's
deploy and learn over time we'll build
systems that learn continuously and
we'll directly observe the operational
figure of Merit over time that way we
can react quickly to real world changes
if the real world changes just we just
change so some people are really good at
this so you
paper from Google the quick paper at
sigcomm last year we see Google directly
observes every day how well quic is
doing and if there's a problem they can
immediately fix it
whether it's automatic or them they can
fix it this is really a world that I
would want to live in it would be very
comfortable deploying something crazy
because you can see immediately how well
it's doing and not just sort of
congestion control but you know in the
real world we do learn over time if I'm
driving a car and something bad happens
to me I'm gonna learn I'm gonna say like
wow I'm definitely not gonna get that
close to a Ferrari next time you want to
learn over time you don't want to just
have a sort of fixed mindset and you
know do it continuously if you build a
robot to change a diaper and the baby
sort of wriggles out of it you want to
learn from that experience you don't
want to be like okay I'm gonna stay
fixed so the sort of continuous learning
has some intuitive appeal but it's hard
it's hard on a network there's some
classical results that make it hard in
cases where information is distributed
so learning is much easier when all the
information comes to one place when
information is distributed it's really
hard and there's some old results that
are therefore you know profound that say
that in some cases it's actually
impossible the impossibility of based
group decision-making with separate
aggregation of beliefs and values so if
you keep the information apart it's
really hard to learn something
consistent you know if you bring all the
information in one place you can do it
but if you keep the information apart
which is what we like to do on a network
we like to be decentralized it's hard to
do so also if agents are adversarial
it's very hard to handle this you know
how do you handle competing agents you
know one guy says oh I've learned this
as best I learned this as best these are
hard problems they're hard Network
problems they're probably should work on
but they're not easy
Michael Shapiro and I actually have a
conjecture that it's impossible for a
decentralized congestion control scheme
that the greedily optimizes an objective
function to be globally asymptotically
stable that's you know it's an unproved
conjecture but it may be hard in these
adversarial cases how about in sort of
the neural networks do we have to just
bring all the data to the cloud and
learn there or just learn in the edge
wouldn't it be nice my student John
Evans is working on this project
just if the data and the compute are in
different places to still be able to
learn without having to bring all the
compute to the edge or all the data to
the cloud be nice to you know sort of
split the problem somehow and even learn
continuously between data and the edge
and computing the cloud and learn
between them unfortunately so far you
can't do it there's like a green region
we want to be in and we're not in there
so lesson two is sort of deploying
learning could be great
it's hard on a network when data's in
different places computes in different
places and people are adversarial so I
think to wrap up good thing I'm most
excited about is this old-fashioned view
that the real benefit of teaching
something to a machine is that you learn
about that thing yourself so we can tell
the machine design a system and the
machine comes you know here are my
requirements for my goals the machine
comes back and says how about this you
know it's better if it looks so weird if
we say that's crazy but huh it does meet
the requirements and it does maximize
the objective that's very interesting
let me clarify my thinking that home is
like the most exciting thing in science
so you know teaching something is the
best way to learn anything
the dumber the student the better the
teacher will learn cuz you have to
explain yourself so clearly machines are
very dumb so teaching machines to learn
to design systems is the best way for us
to learn about what it really means and
what we really care about so to wrap up
here I think paradigm one it gets a lot
of hype but it is harder than we expect
and it is so easy to fool yourself
paradigm - I think we should be working
on I certainly am working on it but the
problems of network systems the
decentralization of data and compute
makes it hard and paradigm 3 I mean I'm
quite sympathetic to it I think even if
we never deploy anything that's the
product of machine learning we should
still do machine learning because we
learned so much about the problem so
yeah we had a sort of set of really
interesting perspectives on the topic of
this panel so I'd like to thank all the
speakers I think what I heard was you
know for problems of an inference nature
like I think you talked about this and I
think Dave also talked about it though
you're trying to figure out where the
fault is in the network and you know
things that it's obviously something
that lends itself well to Kushina
learning I think those you talked about
using data broadly and Kate you had very
interesting perspectives on different
styles of applying machine learning you
know I'd like to just start off with a
question and then we'll open the floor
for the audience to ask questions I
think they're talking people by training
sort of like to be predictable right you
know the RFC specify what protocols must
do and you know if it's not a must it's
at least I should write if if such a
message comes this is what you should do
as a packet loss this is what you should
do and so on so is there a cultural
issue in adapting to a world where you
don't have that predictability you know
the data and the algorithm that you
don't understand tells you something and
you want to make decisions based on that
so do you think there is a inherent
tension there and sort of there's a
little hump that people need to cross to
get comfortable applying machine
learning for more critical networking
decisions so I mean the examples I
talked about there are well-known actual
algorithms that do the job lasso music
and physics guys I was saying there may
be some so for example in the networking
case the neural network doesn't need to
know the adjacency matrix because it's
just a map but it's hidden that's an
advantage
it doesn't need to know the nature of
the noise it's going to learn so I think
it's mostly that you know there's a
certain the fact is the function is
learning that really is most the work
goes in establishing that fact and then
you trying you know using your network
to learn that function and in the case
of music it wasn't straightforward he
really had to work quite hard and so
off-the-shelf stuff doesn't work but it
wasn't it wasn't much doubt that
function is learn about assume because
we know what the function is and it's
called continuous parts and lends itself
just visually even to learn herbal so I
think that's one thing but but this
question of whether you want data or
models the way you train these models
frankly is you need data just to begin
with much of what we did or anybody is
doing it just requires you this whenever
you're trying to learn a function y
equals f of X you need lot of xxiii
pairs and then the function has been
learn about so that's really what what
I've seen so it's not
there may be some cases where you know
the function has some very bad sort of
Lipchitz sort of continuity properties
and then it may be difficult to learn
those bits but otherwise you know so far
it's pretty decent function
approximation examples but broadly about
making networking decisions yeah the
question is one of G's if I have a
system that I don't know exactly how it
works how do I have confidence that I
can actually take action based on its
recommendations and not make things
worse
and you're all go back to the adage
people have a tendency to screw things
up but to really make a big mess takes a
computer so I am trying to hook up
essentially machine learning and
classification systems that are looking
at data to automatic mitigation medic
mechanisms that will go in and change
our network to try and fix problems and
that means is that if that system runs
amok you could actually go create a much
bigger problem for our customers and
then what actually existed there
organically in the network and so for us
it's been this combination of guardrails
around the behavior of this feedback
loop essentially so that no matter what
the classifier says it thinks it should
turn off in order to maybe get a problem
remember that great failure example if I
can find the switch I think is bad I
turn it off everything gets good but if
I turn off all the switches that's bad
so to putting guardrails around so we
don't get kind of runaway behavior and
that if it looks like things are getting
worse and worse then we apply the brakes
to the system and actually start rolling
back some of the changes that were made
in my domain at least we have the
ability to sort of create a closed
feedback loop and that's how we've
approached it certainly our system has
recommended things to us that made no
sense and sometimes it was right
sometimes it was wrong what one of the
things I like about Dave's adage to err
is human but to really foul things up
requires a computer is that it comes
from the 1970s they already knew back
then but I you know when you talk about
concerns about you know whether we have
a system whose behavior we don't really
understand I got to tell you you're
deluded if you think we understand how
this
since we've been building work okay we
already don't understand them it's just
a question of degree I think we taught
the understood and so they felt
comfortable but but going back a little
bit to the specifics of your question
yeah there's this cultural question like
do network engineers want to give up
control to something they don't
understand buy a machine but on the
other hand if you actually look at RFC's
that say should and would that kind of
provides the framework and the more of
that that's in the RFC probably the
better off you are because it says okay
your learning algorithm it's only gonna
have a few knobs it can change and you
have some hope you're gonna understand
it so that you know that that goes both
ways I think it's also this composition
you can probably understand something at
a single level you know it's like when
when you have packets here and then
these protocols that are driving these
packets and then they rely on the
arrival of acknowledgments and that
doesn't happen now something at this
level trigger something at one level
abound that triggers something is that
sort of you know it's almost like a F of
G of H of K you know like you know you
sort of composing now you only see the
first thing and the last thing and you
don't know where it's breaking that sort
of stuff is really hard right you can't
isolate the fault very easily and that's
what frustrates us networking folks
don't we design with understanding but
unfortunately we've composed things now
and they become big and complex
you know there's sort of the sense where
if something has only a small number of
parameters we thought that we understood
it you know T the aimd algorithm in TCP
you know you additive increase by 1/2
there's two parameters and we wrote some
nice proofs and to then discover that
actually the flock behavior of a
decentralized network of computers
owning TCP even with those two
parameters is incredibly complicated has
all kinds of fun things that we discover
you know it's actually chaotic over a
drop tail queue and it's there's
problems like in casts that have to do
with the sort of fact my packet behavior
that or not don't show up in fluid
models so even something with just two
parameters when run in a decentralized
networks situation is so fun but also so
buggy that's a sort of fun and also
humbling discovery and I think there's
an appropriate caution about deploying
something with 100 million learned
parameters you know if we can't even get
the AI and the MD understand those
dynamics you know I think we should be
appropriately humble about our ability
to reason about a system with a million
parameters and doing machine learning to
optimize tale behavior or worst-case
behavior especially in the presence of
adversarial input is an unsolved problem
you know it's one thing to optimize
average case behavior of an image
recognition program but optimizing and
we know that adversarial input to image
recognition is actually like a the
bursary has the better hand there you
know you can change one pixel and
suddenly a puppy turns into the Sears
Tower
so the I think there's an appropriate
caution about you know increasing the
number of parameters and and defining
the guardrail because I think it's such
a good point I don't think we know how
to define the guardrails for many
decentralized scenarios I mean how do
you define stability how do you define a
guardrail when you only observe part of
the situation I mean these are fun the
problems that we should be working on
but I don't think we have the answers I
guess the interesting question is
whether adversarial attacks become more
likely or less likely with machine
learned system versus a handcrafted
system but I think I let's hold on to
that question you know I'd like to open
the floor for questions on the audience
Thanks it it's a song okay I thanks for
a really interesting set of talks so my
question is sort of for more broadly
about the use of training data sets for
machine learning which is fundamental
and obvious problem with such training
data sets is that rare events are by
definition rare and the kind of control
systems didn't need to put into place
for dealing with such events are not
going to be perhaps even available in
the training data set so this critical
dependency on the training data set and
the fact that these data sets may not
include the cases that you care about in
practice makes reliance on machine
learning only as your control system you
know probably bad I think that's a fair
point so the kinds of things that are in
my examples that we're trying to learn
do actually happen a couple of times a
day across the fleet so they're rare but
they happen often enough that we
actually have positive examples and we
can define a false positive false
negative rate on it I still have to have
human engineers on call 24/7 365 because
things will break that has never been
seen before and that any of the
automatic classification systems just
don't know what to do with and then
we're back to good old human
troubleshooting I mean we've tied with
the ideas of trying to actually inject
you know when we have a partial forward
plant model and can predict if this
thing broke what would it look like in
terms of the symptoms we observe trying
to eject more essentially synthetic
failures into our training data mixed
success
any other questions
I guess a question may be following up
on Keith's talk do you think there's a
prospect for designing systems to be
machine learner bol yeah and tell us how
I mean okay systems with a with a
without a lot of high frequency response
are much easier to train a system for
than ones that are very twitchy so I
think we know stability slow evolution
and behavior over time if you you know
good network architecture good system
architecture whether you're trying to
have humans understand what's going on
or an AI system understand what's going
on they're all easier to control yeah I
mean we we've understood for a long time
how to build congestion control
protocols that don't need machine
learning to operate well we just don't
build those systems for whatever reason
you know we use more complicated
mechanisms for coordination than we
really needed to like just because van
invented an algorithm that we all have
to live with now and and so there is
this question I think of if we have
design for testability or designed for
modular design for agility or whatever
do we need a set of design principles
for telling engineers how to build
systems that can actually be predictable
sure I mean I think they involve taking
away the things that make the problem
hard so get rid of decentralization get
rid of adversary's the problem becomes
much easier so you know a congestion
control scheme where there is a central
dictator that governs the allocation of
everybody is much easier to reason about
then a van Jacobson style scheme where
there's a personally observable Markov
decision process that's solved in
decentralized fashion I mean that is a
literally an undecidable problem in
general in computer science so that's
why I can just control so hard if you do
it decentralized if you if you bring all
the information in one place and have a
dictator make the decision it becomes
much easier but maybe observation is is
that there there are many of these kinds
of tussles for another one is not
centralization decentralized but like
you know
time to convergence for efficiency and
optimality sometimes giving up on some
of those dimensions can actually get you
a system that's gonna be far easier to
understand or for simpler but that's
there's a trade-off so maybe there's a I
mean there's sort of an intuitive
feeling that the more you squeeze the
optimization lever in one place all the
other things are gonna get worse so if
you squeeze for great average case
performance you know probably your tails
and your reliability and your bursary
robustness I'm just very informal notion
are gonna get worse and maybe if we stop
squeezing for the thing that gets you
promoted we'll all be happier or I mean
being less glib maybe if we somehow
value these harder to define metrics
instead of just sort of average case
performance or maybe 50% of performance
and stop squeezing so hard on that one
maybe you know understand ability and
stability if we can quantify those we
might be able to optimize for those
instead also it's better chance
subsystems there's no chance of this
being very helpful just because it's
vaguely and it got easier definition of
what if this input Rives I want you know
this is a desirable output I think that
there you can see success is a good
telemetry system that actually gives you
the data that you need from actual
deployment right I mean I think you know
search engines did a great job because
you know they had all the data and sort
of they know exactly what users are
clicking on and so on whereas networking
systems I don't think a lot of data
comes back because it's all over the
place and it's expensive to bring it
back so I think that's challenging I
think we have just a couple more minutes
so I want to ask a final question yeah I
think it's fair to say that overall you
know the whole systems and community and
networking community has a you know a
cautionary approach to infusing em into
the whole the mix you know it's fair you
know a lot of reasons were brought up in
all the presentations when cat outlined
it as well my question is to the
panelists is do you see any sub areas of
systems and networking well it would
actually be better off if we you know
lowered the caution bar and you
and then these systems could evolve
faster and further better
I understand it's not all the sub areas
but any specific serve areas you could
think of how about the scheduler or the
branch predictor you know those kinds of
things and and why is it do you think
that you know loading the caution bar
and those is better than say I don't
know condition I think they're those are
examples perhaps where when there is a
when the when there's a misprediction
the cost isn't so high now David he's
worried about individual packets being
lost that's not the right case then you
might not want to do it but if it's just
a question of well it's just gonna cost
us a little more but we get the same
performance or it's a microscopic change
in performance you don't need to be as
cautious right and that's a low-hanging
fruit especially and you may not need to
know why it made the decision because if
it's wrong it didn't cost you that much
there's totally no way that I couldn't
use quirks of a branch prediction
algorithm and and speculative execution
to steal information out of a process
running that would totally never work
[Laughter]
the query planner in a database I may
think these kinds of things I don't have
any we're already using sort of folklore
methods so why not use a neural network
okay so I think we need to close but I
just sort of take 30 seconds each just
you don't usually ask people to predict
the future but I'm going to change the
question here if you had the machine
learning technology and horsepower that
we have today in the 80s when you know
congestion control took shape or in the
90s when you know bgp was designed or
you know maybe the 2000s when firewalls
and deep packet inspection and so on
came to the fore how would things have
been done differently that would perhaps
make us better off today you know if you
had to redesign things with the machine
learning technologies available today
well what would have happened
differently just quick okay I can go
first I'm just sending the example as a
music thing it learns the environment so
you you come out of the shell with an
algorithm that works in many
environments
well but not optimized for anything
can't be and then you deploy in a
particular like in your indoor home area
you got so VR headset nothing really
works differently in the basement room
versus here this money's work well I
think that's an example of something
where the adaptive to the environment I
think that if we'd had this horsepower
in the 80s I would have been able to say
okay Google why is the network so slow
and it would say I'm sorry I can't help
you with that and that's the kind of
thing it's good at right it's
recognizing patterns can understand my
my question but it doesn't know the
answer okay thank you just control the
truth is that people have been talking
about congest control in the context of
machine learning for since it started I
mean Kev's paper on packet pair that
talks about the then prevailing paradigm
of machine learning which was fuzzy
logic that's right right yeah I mean
it's all about fuzzy logic which was the
thing and you know the early 90s I bet
if I bet if deep neural networks had
been around then you were in the exact
same paper but you would have subbed out
fuzzy logic for neural networks but
nothing would have changed about the
algorithm so I I don't know okay last
word yeah I'm not really coming up with
one either the one thing I do know is
whenever Skynet tries to take over the
world it will probably crash because of
a networking problem okay let's thank
our panel again
[Applause]